[Musique]
le barcares parce que 20 places ces dix
ans de ma vie s'il en bonheur avec le
public à partager avec toutes les
équipes
par quels sont ses dépens si c'est le
jeu est un jeu de société qui est
vachement bien lancé par cap c'est bien
vous qui touche les gens c'est ce
qu'affirment les pommes tard car
évidemment remarquable très bien car
c'est forcément alexandra c'est là rené
en sabre ici comme super combiné la
rentrée alors pour les élèves ça sera
pour moi dark and quiet man aux dépens
d'al qarara sera c'est un peu les deux
cas j'adore je vais une fois j'ai pas lu
les araignées donc par caf
s'il ya les araignées rats ça j'en ai
failli subir le stress car c'est bien
elle stresse il en faut c'est à dire
pour les concernés et lui dit pas